good morning Hank it's Tuesday so it was
recently brought to my attention that if
you search for my name on Google the
very first video result is a video you
made in 2011 Hank called John Green is
an idiot now don't get me wrong it's a
great video it's just not necessarily
the first video I want associated with
my name so today I thought I would try
to replace that video by making a video
in which I answer questions that people
asked Google about me beginning with is
John Green dead no well actually I guess
it depends on when you're watching this
but not currently where did John Green
live does does where does John Green
live I am Alive I live in Indianapolis
where my books The Fault in Our Stars
and Turtles all the way down are set
before that I lived in Chicago were part
of an abundance of katherines is set and
before that I lived in Birmingham
Alabama where Looking for Alaska is set
and before that I lived in Orlando
Florida where Paper Towns is said I am
NOT given over to acts of geographical
imagination what books did John Green
wrote I guess we're just living in a
world without verb tenses I wrote the
books listed above as well as half of
Will Grayson Will Grayson and one-third
of let it snow when did John Green
published his first book 2005 look at
that little child trying to be serious
for his author photo are John and Hank
green related yes we are brothers and
know there are no other siblings well
except for Dave but we don't talk about
Dave is Hank or John Green older I'm
just gonna revel in the fact that that's
a question people have asked Google is
John Green a Hufflepuff I am quite
proudly I might add what is the meaning
of dftba
it's an initialism for several phrases
including don't forget to be awesome and
darling fetch the battle ax and also
Dave forgotten through brotherly
adventures is John Green married I am
does John Green have a child I actually
have two does John Green have a podcast
I also have two of those is John Green
banned from Canada no but I do have to
go through extra screening when entering
Canada because I am on a list of
potential undesirables due to the fact
that I was denied entrance to Canada in
1995 for insufficient funds
what is john green's cameo in The Fault
in Our Stars movie right so my cameo was
cut from the movie because I am a
terrible actor that noted the scene is
available as a DVD extra and also on
YouTube does John Green have a Hollywood
star
a John Green does but he is not me he
was a composer who won five Academy
Awards for scoring such movies
an American in Paris and West Side Story
although today he is mostly forgotten
which is a nice reminder that no matter
what you do the tides of time will wash
away your sandcastle so there's no sense
in reaching for some foolhardy notion of
immortality when there's real work to be
done with real people right now but what
were we talking about right now I don't
have a star on the Hollywood Walk of
Fame which john green book should I read
I mean I'm a little biased but I think
you should read all of them is John
Green writing a new book possibly but
it's hard to know for sure does John
Green like soccer yes enough to sponsor
a third tier English soccer team which
by the way over the weekend might have
avoided relegation by coming back from
to nail down at half-time to win 3-2 on
the last kick of the game I wept I'm not
embarrassed to say it I cried like a
baby Henry said why are you crying isn't
it happy yes it's happy what kind of
music does John Green listen to I
listened to the early stuff from the
mountain goats and also the more recent
stuff by the mountain goats what is a
nerdfighter John Green so Hank and I
have been making videos here at
vlogbrothers for more than 11 years and
the people in the community that's grown
up around these videos call themselves
nerdfighters because they fight for
intellectual engagement and celebrate an
ironic enthusiasm did John Green won any
awards my books have won a prince award
and an Edgar Award but most prestigious
Lee an MTV Movie Award if I just get
four more of these maybe I'll get one of
those Hollywood stars did John Green
start at VidCon this can't go on any
longer I just need to leave some quick
feedback for Google verb tenses I
technically co-founded VidCon but only
because I was on the phone with my
brother when he came up with the idea
actually that's true for most of the
stuff we've made together like when I
look at my Wikipedia page I mostly just
think man look at all these things Hank
did while I was writing books okay if
you have any other questions please
leave them in comments I'll answer as
many as I can Hank I will see you on
Friday